donc dans un premier temps où avez-vous
rencontré Monsieur Sifaoui comment état
de vos relations voilà je vous remercie
pour votre question monsieur le
Président qui va me permettre je
l'espère de clarifier un certain nombre
de choses je j'ai eu l'occasion de le
dire mais je le dis et sincèrement et
dans ce contexte et face à cette
commission je ne suis pas une amie de
Monsieur Sifaoui et je le dis parce que
dans un premier temps c'est ce qui a été
rapporté et c'est ce qui a été dit je le
dément il est
difficile de démontrer qu'on n'est pas
ami avec quelqu'un si on dit je ne suis
pas amie et qu'en face on nous dit si
vous êtes amis monsieur CIFA oui
lui-même s'est exprimé sur BFM TV et a
dit également je ne suis pas un ami de
Madame Schiappa
le terme ami est un mot-valise alors
je vais éliminer je vais éliminer les
hypothèses une par une monsieur le
Président
qui est la laïcité voilà je éliminer une
par une monsieur le Président si vous me
le permettez toutes ces hypothèses je ne
suis pas une amie de Monsieur Sifaoui je
n'ai aucune relation personnelle
d'aucune sorte avec Monsieur cifaoui et
je n'en ai jamais eu je ne suis pas avec
Monsieur cifaoui membre de même
organisation nous ne nous retrouvons pas
dans tel ou tel association ou
organisation en dehors de mon action
ministérielle je n'ai pas l'occasion de
rencontrer Monsieur cifaoui dans aucun
lieu privé ni chez lui ni chez moi ni
dans une activité sportive et je peux
vous faire l'intégralité de la liste je
ne connais pas sa vie personnelle ni sa
famille il ne connaît pas la mienne bref
nous ne sommes pas amis nous ne sommes
pas dans sans associés nous n'avons pas
d'intérêt commun et nous ne sommes
ensemble à ma connaissance membre
d'aucune organisation puisque c'est
aussi le sous-jacent de pas de vous
monsieur le Président mais de certaines
formulations qui ont
été faites moi monsieur Sifaoui je le
vois à plusieurs reprises et pas en tête
à tête et je tiens à le dire ici parce
que l'un des témoignages qui a été
apporté devant votre commission à
affirmer que j'aurai reçu
personnellement en tête-à-tête monsieur
Sifaoui au mois de mars et que ce serait
à cette occasion que je lui aurais
annoncé qu'il aurait une subvention ou
qu'il serait éligible au fond Marianne
c'est faux
c'est faux je tiens à le dire ici sous
serment c'est faux je le dis et c'est
documenté par l'ensemble de mon agenda
et des échanges de messages avec mon
cabinet j'ai un message d'un de mes
conseillers daté environ du 20 avril
peut pro qui d'ailleurs m'interpelle en
me disant que je n'ai pas rencontré
Monsieur sifflet de mémoire dans son
mail il dit vous devriez rencontrer
recevoir Monsieur cifaoui donc moi j'ai
participé à des événements ministériels
auxquels monsieur Sifaoui était présent
notamment et je l'ai lu dans la presse
ou dans un rapport ce que j'en avais pas
souvenir j'ai fait un déplacement dans
le Tarn et Monsieur Siffert
je crois à ma connaissance par le SVC
PDR pour délivrer une formation à cette
occasion nous ne sommes pas je n'ai pas
moi congé monsieur Sifaoui à venir
j'étais présente et il était présent il
est intervenu également il a également
participé à une visioconférence avec
d'autres experts
que je peux citer si vous le souhaitez
dans le cadre des travaux préparatoires
à la loi séparatiste puisqu'il était un
interlocuteur du cipdr monsieur cifaoui
était en lien avec le cpdr longtemps
avant ma propre nomination il y a des
comptes rendus qui sont dans les
dossiers qui montrent qu'il est reçu et
qu'il a des entretiens avec le cipdr ce
qui n'est pas anormal puisque c'est à ce
moment un acteur reconnu de l'écosystème
de la lutte contre l'islamisme il a
publié des ouvrages il fait des
interventions et donc il fait partie des
acteurs consultés par le cipdr mais je
tiens à être clair et formel sur le fait
que nous ne sommes pas amis nous n'avons
pas de relation personnelle et nous
n'avons pas d'intérêt commun ou
d'appartenance communes à ma
connaissance à tel ou tel organisation
j'espère avoir été clair monsieur le
Président la réponse est claire en tout
cas